suite
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
à
la piscine je souhaite dans la piscine
ça y est vue il est super content il
n'ya pas avoir loana qui va venir dans
un instant on aura également évident
thomas qui va tenir mon chéri et il ya
tous les autres je vous le dis reste
avec nous juste pour voir la tête nos
jours luc lemoine sur la tête de ma mère
celui qui rigole pas c'est que il était
bleu de la masa alors oui bon rester là
donc on va commencer avec avec avec avec
afida turner pas les bras
ah oui
[Musique]
moi je vous feriez on peu pas mal la
vraie musique de love story coup tout le
monde connaît au lieu de métier jean
gaubert s'était c'était pas mon émission
mais obama peut accueillir
faut y aller avec un voile à mugello
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
ah oui alors lâchez pas ce qu'est ce qui
l'assurait décoincer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
jean vous pouvez voter pour le meilleur
déguisement sait déjà qui sera pas moi
mais à mon avis je pense que ce sera
jean luc lemoine c'est pas mal isabelle
tepa bâle s'est jamais les pharmaciens
valises mails puis c'est plutôt de tony
tony de koh lanta
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonne joueuse hitomi de koh lanta je
suis le meilleur ami de moundir et je
peux te le dire les phone 7 un os les
vitrines comme tous ces très jolies je
dors mais comme tout bon des fois tu es
sacrément déçu de ce que tu trouves
dedans tout est faussé pas de moustache
font qu'un amer vous allez voir tout à
l'heure il ya la vraie loi naquit
variées vous allez voir la
transformation
c'est ouf on jouera les magnifiques à
madonna ouais c'est maintenant on à greg
le millionnaire et il le fait bien il le
sait bien les grecs 2002 améliorée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et toi comment tu te sens je me suis
toujours de porte ou tu es tu vas y
arriver
non c'est mon père c'est sûr oui merci
ok c'est tout mais moi c'est bon d'être
là non non pas ses peintures de carrière
à ceux ci à wimille s'ébattant on va
recevoir ce type
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la rigolade c'est quand même lui
dallas même jeter quand il faisait
titeuf en alsace médias
c'est le même cas il fait titoff tout le
temps fait sam hba1c ses vrais cheveux
mais j en tout cas vous allez à fond à
chaque fois voter pour le meilleur
déguisement et surtout ne manquez pas
jean-luc lemoine quoi cela là on a un
petit désastre c'est quoi bah c'est
brandon de l'île
[Musique]
ces catastrophes
oberson femme elle est où ma femme et
moi j'avais ces deux petites celui qui
se prend pour un comédien il à fond dans
tous les rôles
1 le bâton tu vas prendre et tu sénat
recherche diana diana ma femme j'ai un
gros problème et vous souhaite bien ah
ouais je sais bravo jean mi merci quel
acteur et wii est le meilleur pour la
fin évidemment il a la latitude on dit
mais moi je sais même pas qui c'était en
fait qu'il est arrivé dans lost à leur
féminité qui watts en fait c'est qui le
gard le voit c'est impressionnant c'est
mathieu giuseppe
[Applaudissements]
c'était
c'est avant tout rester devant soirée
s'est demandé comment un peuple en cette
date les seuils vous allez voter pour le
meilleur déguisement mais juste un truc
ce soir là il ya quelqu'un qui est pas
du tout au courant je vous dis je vais
faire une surprise à une personne de
l'équipe qui n'est pas du tout au
courant je suis demandé à la caméra de
bien vouloir me suivre benjamin castaldi
au fait il était en bonne voie gastaldi
bourget
[Musique]